ziya's peace yeah is non-negotiable
gabrielle union is opening up about her
stepdaughter zia's experience
coming out and she is not holding back
the actress who is married to ziya's
father
dwayne wade joined taraji p henson and
tracy j
jenkins on the premiere episode of the
facebook watch series
peace of mind with taraji and shared
some disturbing news about the 13 year
old's journey
as xayah gathered more language
she was able to tell us about her
identity
she was able to tell us about her
sexuality she was able to tell us
i'm trans and she says i've come
out a few times and she was like well
you know i came out to my teacher in the
third grade
and then when you guys posted that
picture of me in chicago at my birthday
party and it's just
zaya standing next to her cake and that
picture was dissected on certain black
blogs
and the comments were the guessing as to
whose ayah was and why and she said i
felt like i was outed
and i was just standing next to my cape
gabrielle continues to share that ziya
who came out back in february with the
love and support of her parents
continues to teach them a thing or two
of what it means to be
lgbtq plus allies she spoke of coming
out again
when she was like i'm trans
i'm demi you know sexual like i'm
i'm not bound by you know gender in
terms of you know attraction or whatever
when xayah asked for um a demi flag a
demi uh
you know there's all different kinds of
flags yeah she asked for
a demisexual flag for her birthday and
uh dee was like do you know what that is
i'm like no
and so we're like yeah no problem we're
right on that run
right and then we're like okay so your
demi
so it's just the personality of the
person
you know i was like okay yeah that's
great diego so are you still trans
and so i was like identity
is not the same as sexuality is not the
same as
gender expression
[Laughter]
say it louder for the people in the back
i love that gabrielle you know coming
out really is a traumatic experience for
so many people within the queer
community
gabrielle also shared her own
experiences with ptsd
saying that quarantine has not been the
relaxing experience
she thought it might be you said that
2020 has been triggering to you ptsd how
are you holding up gab
i thought quarantining was right up my
alley
i love silence i love hunkering down at
home
but you add in our president he inspired
so much racism and white supremacy and
hatred and evil
that we have been in the midst of an
onslaught
a daily barrage of the brutalization of
black and brown bodies
that we're just taking in every day all
day
and host taraji couldn't agree more
explaining
why ptsd isn't just something that
affects soldiers
just turning the news on once you turn
it off your body goes through something
that's ptsd that's pts it's just such a
trigger it is not one size fits all
there's a misconception when we say ptsd
people don't
understand that it comes in different
forms it's not
just from being in the service because
we do associate ptsd
with soldiers we forget that we are
surviving wars in our neighborhoods
every day
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos